herr merz ist es in diesen tagen ganz
viel von wumms die räder ein paket mit
wumms wer zahlt am ende den wumms naja
die zahlen sind schon einigermaßen wir
fast sagen schwindelerregend jedenfalls
für normale zeiten wären sie das nun
leben wir nicht in normalen zeiten es
muss jetzt wirklich geklotzt werden und
darf nicht gekleckert werden aber
richtig ist natürlich auch am ende des
tages wird das vor allem den
bundeshaushalt sehr stark belasten
ich sehe mit einem gewissen unbehagen
der bundeshaushalt ihr den ganz großen
teil der lasten trägt man spricht von
bis zu 90 prozent obwohl die länder ab
dem nächsten jahr die höheren
steuereinnahmen haben werden aber gut
das ist jetzt so die nächste generation
wird einen großen teil davon ab bezahlen
müssen aber das ganze geschieht ja auch
damit die arbeitsplätze auch für die
junge generation erhalten bleiben also
das ist eine große kraftanstrengung über
die richtung
sie haben gerade das stichwort genannt
arbeitsplätze die erhalten bleiben
müssten für die nächste generation
nun sind millionen deutsche gerade in
kurzarbeit damit ende des jahres die
arbeitslosenzahlen nicht dramatisch
steigen hat man das kurzarbeitergeld
jetzt auch verlängert wie viel welche
auswirkungen erwarten sie auf den
arbeitsmarkt wenn dieses
kurzarbeitergeld aus der werden die
menschen zurückkehren zu ihren
arbeitsplätzen oder sind von den 67
millionen dann am ende auf einmal 2 3
millionen in der arbeitslosenstatistik
zu finden erreicht das kann zum jetzigen
zeitpunkt niemand mit gewissheit
voraussagen wir können zunächst einmal
froh und dankbar sein dass sie dieses
kurzarbeitergeld in deutschland haben
schauen sie einmal in länder die solche
instrumente nicht kennen wenn sie allein
mal in den usa sehen wie dort die
arbeitslosigkeit innerhalb von tagen
nach oben geschnellt ist das ist uns bis
jetzt gott sei dank erspart geblieben
das kurzarbeitergeld ist eine
überbrückung für eine schwierige zeit
diese schwierige zeit die wird jetzt
länger dauern aber wir werden natürlich
uns mit dem gedanken beschäftigen müssen
das zum herbst die arbeitslosigkeit in
deutschland auch ausgewiesen deutlich
ansteigt
nur es nützt alles nichts wir müssen
jeden versuch unternehmen aus dieser
rezession schnell wieder heraus zu
kommen und dafür sind die instrumente
jetzt noch einmal nachgeschärft worden
und wir können alle nur hoffen dass sie
dann auch wirklich die erwünschte
wirkung zum jahresende erzielen wir
werden in einigen monaten klüger sein
aber ich bin zuversichtlich dass wir
dann auch rückblickend sagen das waren
die richtigen entscheidungen
die richtigen entscheidungen fragen wir
nochmal danach beim thema
automobilindustrie die wollten etwas
vergleichbares mit der abwrackprämie
auch für verbrenner deutsche
automobilindustrie müssen wir hier nicht
groß besprechen ist quasi die herzkammer
der deutschen wirtschaft bekommen haben
sie am ende zumindest für die
technologie verbrenner exakt nix ist
dieser umgang mit einer deutschen
spitzentechnologie so richtig ich mache
kein geheimnis daraus erreicht dass ich
von solchen kaufprämien immer schon
relativ wenig gehalten habe vor zehn
jahren war die lage anders wir hatten
durch die finanzkrise einen massiven
nachfrageeinbruch wir haben aber dieses
mal eine völlig andere krise ihr
wirtschaftskrise die rezession die wir
jetzt sehen ist durch einen weltweiten
angebots schock und ein nachfragesog
ausgelöst insofern finde ich die
gewichtung in dem konjunkturpaket auch
richtig zu sagen wir müssen auch nicht
nur aber auch auf die
wettbewerbsfähigkeit der industrie
achten und dann die nachfrage
gleichzeitig stimulieren und ich denke
das wird durch die absenkung der
mehrwertsteuer gelingen man muss ganz
offen und deutlich auch dazu sagen diese
mehrwertsteuerabsenkung wird natürlich
nicht eins zu eins an alle
verbraucherinnen und verbraucher
weitergegeben das wird ein teil davon
sein aber nicht alles das was in den
unternehmen verbleibt stärkt dann
gleichzeitig aber auch die
eigenkapitalausstattung der unternehmen
stärkt die wettbewerbsfähigkeit der
unternehmen
und insofern ist das ein gemischtes bild
war da was die mehrwertsteuerabsenkung
betrifft aber sie erreicht natürlich
auch die automobilindustrie
aber eben nicht nur und insofern halte
ich dieses instrument das ja für die
meisten von uns einigermaßen
überraschend kam ich halte dieses
instrument auch für richtig halte es
auch für besser als wir eine als eine
einseitige prämie zugunsten des kaufens
neue autos viel wird derzeit gesprochen
über die kommunikation mit den menschen
was sagt man den menschen die jetzt zum
beispiel ihre existenz verlieren um ihre
existenz oder um ihren job bangen was
sagt man ihnen in bezug auf die nächsten
monate auf die nächsten jahre vielleicht
was da kommt 30 prozent einbruch beim
deutschen export acht -8%
negativwachstum alles zahlen die wir so
zu lebzeiten noch nicht erlebt haben was
sagen sie den menschen was da auf uns
zukommt welche form von krise kommt auf
und zu worauf müssen sich die menschen
in diesem land einstellen zunächst
einmal haben sie natürlich recht mit
ihrer beschreibung erreicht das ist eine
rezession in einem ausmaß wie wir sie zu
unseren lebzeiten noch nie gesehen haben
das kann man allenfalls mit der
weltwirtschaftskrise in den 30er jahren
vergleichen aber auch dieser vergleich
hinkt in vielfältiger weise
und jetzt tut die staatengemeinschaft in
europa aber auch die bundesrepublik
deutschland und die regierungen nicht
nur die bundesregierung sondern auch die
landesregierung ja unglaublich viel um
schnell wieder aus dieser krise
herauszukommen
diese kraftanstrengung ist einmalig
gleichzeitig muss man vielen betroffenen
sagen der staat kann jeden ausgefallenen
umsatz ersetzen es geht einfach objektiv
nicht insofern wird es natürlich auch in
zwei unternehmensinsolvenzen geben
es wird eine steigende arbeitslosigkeit
geben aber dieser sozialstaat ist
leistungsfähig genug um dafür zu sorgen
dass hier niemand ins bodenlose fällt es
wird eine schwierige zeit nicht viel
hinzufügen wir werden nicht wieder an
die zeit anknüpfen die wir vorher gehabt
haben
also zurück zur alten normalität vor
corona wird es in dieser form nicht
geben wir werden eine neue normalität
erleben und diese neue normalität die
kann wenn wir es richtig machen auch mit
einem technologieschub verbunden sein
mit wirklichen innovationen mit einer
besseren infrastruktur vor allem einer
besseren digitalen infrastruktur und
wenn uns das gelingt dann liegt eben in
dieser krise auch eine wirkliche chance
und dann kann es sein dass wir sozusagen
im zeitraffer jetzt erleben dass eine
modernisierung unserer volkswirtschaft
stattfindet wie wir sie auch ohne die
krise hätten machen müssen aber jetzt
geht eben alles sehr viel schneller und
das ist sozusagen ein optimistischer
blick nach vorn
es kann danach sogar besser sein das ist
der optimistische blick in die zukunft
aber derzeit schauen viele menschen
natürlich angst dafür den sorgenvoll auf
das was passiert wir haben in den
letzten tagen darüber berichtet über
klein und kleinstunternehmer die unter
den crooner regeln ganz massiv leiden
und dann zum beispiel nach berlin auf
den alexanderplatz nach münchen auf die
großdemonstration geblickt haben wo
diese krone regeln auf einmal nicht mehr
galten oder nicht mehr durchgesetzt
wurden wie haben sie diese bilder von
den großen demonstrationen vom
vergangenen wochenende wahrgenommen
also ganz ehrlich meine meine erste
spontane reaktion erreicht war als ich
diese bilder gesehen habe
muss das denn jetzt seien das ist nicht
sehr vernünftig was da stattgefunden hat
ich kann die sorgen der menschen
verstehen um ihre arbeitsplätze um ihre
firmen um die unternehmen viele auch mit
jungen unternehmen auf der anderen seite
corona ist nicht vorbei wir werden eine
lange zeit noch mit dem virus leben
müssen und mit dem virus zu leben heißt
sich verantwortungsvoll zu verhalten
große menschenmengen zu vermeiden
mundschutz tücher zu tragen
also ich habe auch hier die bitte an die
bevölkerung ja bei allem verständnis für
protest und der protest ist ja zum teil
auch gerechtfertigt gegen diese
einschränkungen die zum teil auch nicht
sehr logisch in sich sind und nicht sehr
schlüssig aber bitte achten sie darauf
dass dann trotzdem die gesundheit
geschützt wird und zwar nicht nur ihre
eigene sondern auch diejenige unserer
mitbürgerinnen und mitbürger wir wollen
gemeinsam schnell raus aus der infektion
und das geht nur wenn sich jeder in
diesem land wirklich verantwortungsvoll
verhält sie haben jetzt vor allem die
demos gegen die korona maßnahmen
angesprochenen aber ein ebenso großes
thema waren auch die black lips meter
demonstration mit teilweise 15 20 25.000
menschen dicht an dicht gedrängt haben
sie das sorge dass coroner regeln nur so
lange gelten wie es sozusagen nicht für
das richtige wo wir uns alle einig sind
demonstriert wird
reichelt ich habe allergrößtes
verständnis dafür dass viele menschen
auch diese einschränkungen ihres alltags
leid sind
ich habe ja nun selbst auch corona
gehabt und ich stand 14 tage unter
quarantäne und musste mich da sehr
einschränken
alles in ordnung ich beschwere mich
nicht aber ich weiß dass es schwer ist
und trotzdem muss man an die vernunft
appellieren und wenn es dann darum geht
gegen rassismus zu demonstrieren ja
aber lassen sie mich das mal so sagen
ich wäre in amerika er auf die straße
gegangen als in deutschland
wir haben in deutschland dieses problem
in diesem umfang nicht wie wir diese
schrecklichen bilder der aus amerika in
den letzten wochen wieder einmal gesehen
haben und insofern muss jeder für sich
persönlich abwägen was er tut und in der
abwägung komme ich zu dem ergebnis dass
es in den augenblicklichen zeiten besser
ist an solchen demonstrationen nicht
teilzunehmen
man kann seinen wunsch nach
gleichbehandlung und nach anerkennung
menschenwürde respekt vor den menschen
und auch vor anderen auch in anderer
weise ausdrücken dafür muss man jetzt
nicht auf große demonstrationen gehen
die zeit kommt hoffentlich bald wieder
dass das alles ohne weiteres möglich ist
aber die zeiten sind eben jetzt nicht
danach
sie haben 1929 und die rezession der
30er jahre selber angesprochen wenn auch
gesagt lässt sich nicht alles so eins zu
eins vergleichen aber natürlich ist für
das politische klima das
gesellschaftliche klima in einem land
wenig bedrohlicher als eine große
rezession mit großer rasant steigender
arbeitslosigkeit was ist wie blicken sie
im moment auf deutschland laufen wir
gefahr uns in einer rezession in einer
wirtschaftskrise noch weiter zu
polarisieren als das vielleicht ohnehin
schon der fall ist
nein herr reichelt auch da habe ich ein
ganz zuversichtlich und optimistischen
blick also ich lese gerade das neue buch
von matthias horx über die zeit nach
corona und der beschreibt interessante
sachverhalte und das sind beobachtungen
die ich auch mache also zum beispiel die
angst der menschen vor der zukunft hat
erstaunlicherweise während der korona
krise sogar abgenommen
es gibt eine neue zuversicht es gibt
eine neue nachbarschaft
es gibt ein neues bewusstsein wie
wertvoll nicht nur materielle werte
sondern auch ideelle werte in unserer
gesellschaft sind dass der zusammenhalt
in dieser gesellschaft plötzlich sehr
viel größer wird dass sich die
prioritäten verändern und insofern bin
ich da gar nicht so pessimistisch ja wir
sind in einer rezession wir kommen nicht
rein wir sind in einer rezession
wir haben die chance da auch relativ
schnell wieder heraus zu kommen auch
wenn es eine gewisse zeit dauern wird
aber die welt danach kann in
vielfältiger hinsicht anders aussehen
sie kann vielleicht sogar ein wenig
entschleunigt sein es kann sein dass wir
plötzlich andere prioritäten gemeinsam
setzen dass sich das gesellschaftliche
klima zum besseren hin wende dass es
nicht immer nur so hektisch zugeht und
so ellebogen mäßig also da bin ich
zuversichtlich aber wir müssen nun
zunächst einmal diese durststrecke
durchstehen und die wird uns einige
wochen und monate begleiten vielleicht
sogar wissen das wahljahr 20 21 hinein
aber dann ist es eben auch eine große
chance mit der bevölkerung in diesen
dialog einzutreten und sagen welche
bundesrepublik deutschland welche
europäische union wollen wir eigentlich
in den nächsten zehn jahren
wer wird die cdu in diesem wahlkampf
hören herr merz reichelt das ist eine
frage die wir wahrscheinlich erst im
januar nächsten jahres beantworten der
zeitplan steht wir werden auf dem
bundesparteitag der cdu im dezember wenn
nicht noch einmal eine zweite welle
dazwischen kommen sollte mit infektionen
aber wir gehen jetzt alle mal davon aus
wir werden am dritten dezember in
stuttgart einen neuen parteivorsitzenden
wählen
dieser neue parteivorsitzende wird
danach sofort mit der csu in einem
gespräch gehen und dann wird es eine
gemeinsame entscheidung von cdu und csu
für einen gemeinsamen kanzlerkandidaten
für die bundestagswahl 2021 geben und
wie sicher sind sie dass der neue
parteivorsitzende friedrich merz heißen
wird ich bin sehr zuversichtlich aber es
sind noch sechs monate bis dahin und da
kann noch sehr viel passieren ich
bereite mich jedenfalls sehr sorgfältig
und intensiv auf diese zeit vor und
insbesondere auf dem parteitag